that's right more trailers from Comic
Con to talk about in true fashion in all
things that are tradition we got some
cool trailers and then some really cool
people who boot like the trailer and
shut it online and now we just all get
to watch it I guess Warner Brothers was
best about it so they were like well
screw it if people can see it they might
as well see it in high-def which is
funny they're talking about like it's
some weird new phenomenon people have
been bootlegging comic-con trailers for
as long as comic-con has been showing
comic-con trailer but in the world where
we all now get to sit and enjoy it this
Suicide Squad trailer is awesome it's a
cool premise first of all and the
premise is exactly what you knew the
Suicide Squad was Amanda Waller's like
hey I got a team together and this teams
are pretty shitty people and I can
control him because I'm an [ __ ]
because Amanda Waller's an [ __ ] and
ultimately this trailer just shows
imagery and some of the imagery and the
characters that we're talking about
first of all Killer Croc looks really
good in this movie I didn't know if you
would the picture I saw just look kind
of stupid [ __ ] that's why pictures are
worth a thousand words but videos worth
a thousand pictures and enchanters looks
messed up I love the fact that in
chanters is even in it because when you
start thinking about it you're like she
is straight-up magic and all of these
comic-book movies they've had science
they've had crazy they've had tech
they've had a world where it's science
and magic but it's a world was one in
the same but now she's magic Kyle Smith
is dead shot looks good really funny
that Will Smith as Deadshot had the
titular lines like we're the Suicide
Squad I was like that's really funny
because an arrow Deadshot's the one that
called in the Suicide Squad there too is
like Deadshot gets to name it all the
time the one I'm going to talk about the
most here is Harley Quinn Margot Robbie
as Harley Quinn right when I heard she
was Harley Quinn Hales like that's
perfect and I see her in the trailer and
I'm like she looks [ __ ] awesome cuz
she just does she is super sexy this is
the hottest Margot Robbie has ever been
and I have seen Margot Robbie and a few
things but apparently I just like a
little bit of crazy who licks the bars
in her cell which is important because
she's getting iron in her diet which
means she's smart because she knows that
jokes aside I do want to see that I do
want to see a Harley Quinn who's not
just crazy like a bat Blaine is DJ I
want to see a Harley how I think they're
doing it in here where she was dr.
Harleen Quinzel and then she got messed
up and she's still intelligent but she's
just a broken person she's crazy she's
out there but she's not a cartoon I
think margot robbie has a great shot at
showing some solid humanity in Harley
Quinn you see this one see it's like if
you blink you miss it but Batman's on
top of that car it's like straight up
bad this is like Batman impersonator guy
earlier on in the trailer and you see
Batman at the car and you start frame by
frame you're like no
Batman she's pretty me that he's cameo
in this movie and I heard this takes
place before Batman V Superman which
means my theory about Batman V Superman
how Bruce Wayne hasn't been Batman for
years is probably not true at all that's
why it's fun to theorize with videos
though didn't in the end you hear the
laugh ah ah ah but also you look at the
Dark Knight when the Joker came to the
mob in their little kitchen he laughed a
lot the same way ah ah ah hee hee
all right Joker's gonna have his laugh
laugh which they're probably saving for
the movie that he has is like sarcastic
clap the scene where he's torturing
someone he's like I'm not gonna kill you
I'm just gonna hurt you really really
bad I thought that might have been Jason
Todd because you see the Robin outfit in
the Batman V Superman trailer I was like
okay well that scene in Suicide Squad
he's torturing and killing Jason Todd
done right yeah probably not though
because you see someone strapped down
and it shows tattoos on the person
totally the Joker has Harley quibble
Harleen Quinzel before she was Harley
Quinn I think that's what happened he is
tortured this [ __ ] out of her and broke
her mind which then you're like how is
Harley going to interact with the Joker
I mean he's totally gonna be like
Stockholm Syndrome he's gonna be like
that but in the end she's gonna be like
you know what no [ __ ] that [ __ ] he
messed me up she's gonna try to kill him
like what's gonna happen and I will say
this from what I saw in the one scene in
this trailer I like Jared Leto as the
Joker and in my video where I talked
about Jared Leto as the Joker when they
revealed his picture in it all the
tattoos and [ __ ] I said then and I say
now Jared Leto is a great pick for the
Joker
he'll probably act the part he will be
great in the movie I just don't like all
the on the nose tattooing but I do like
the voice I like the persona he looks
like a dick like he's an [ __ ] it
looks like the kind of person where if
that dude beat and killed Jason Todd you
look at him you're like you don't
deserve to do that because you're a dude
that's what the scott snyder story death
of the family did at a point I was like
this guy's an [ __ ] and I feel bad for
liking him so if Jared Leto's Joker does
that for me I will be golden and I'll
tell you I love it when the UM actually
people get there um actually shoved
right back in their faces like when I
was bitching about the Joker tattoos and
the UM actually people came out of the
woodwork of the comment section and they
were like actually my best friend
sisters boyfriends brothers girlfriends
the Photoshop expert nieces the tattoos
are all Photoshop they're not even real
[ __ ] were they good that way and now
apparently not cuz they're all there I
will say this DC is really doing a good
job on their trailer whether or not they
pull everything off the way they want to
pull it off in the execution of the
movie ID
not what the trailers are great because
it shows you some really great imagery
some solid scenes easy enough to
theorize gives you enough to talk about
you're intrigued you like what you see
for the most part but in the end you
don't have the context to piece it
together so you don't really know what
you're seeing really so you still have
enough to be surprised when you watch
the movie earlier oh wow the trailer
didn't spoil everything that's fantastic
you start going amazing spider-man
honestly like stop stop right now
so the Suicide Squad trailer guys have
you seen it what did you think about it
where you thought comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more